good afternoon so let's start with that
breaking news a number of migrants have
drowned in the english channel as they
tried to make the crossing from france
to the uk let's go straight to the
newsroom now and join sky's laura
bundock who's following the story i
guess details still coming in but what
more do we know so far
well we've heard from the french
interior minister gerald armand who has
confirmed that many people have drowned
in the channel this afternoon he's now
making his way to calais to be at the
scene we understand it was about two
o'clock this afternoon that french
fishermen spotted a boat in trouble in
the channel we don't yet know the exact
numbers of people who have drowned but
it is as i say understood to be many now
we think that the conditions at the time
in the channel were calm but very cold
you don't normally expect this time of
the year to have so many people trying
to make crossings however we have seen
big numbers recently i think down to the
fact that conditions have been
relatively stable at the moment this
could potentially be the biggest number
of lives lost in a day for several for
several months now back in october last
year four people drowned but we think
that today's number could sadly be many
more this of course has been um a
sticking point between the british and
the french governments the british have
criticized the french for not doing
enough to try and stop these smuggling
gangs who are putting people on the
boats on the french side
we know that many times it's young
families in these boats that they aren't
properly equipped with boats who can
make that treacherous journey across to
travel life jackets often not provided
either but as i say news still coming in
but we understand that many people this
afternoon of fear to have drowned in
this latest incident